[Music]
in the case of everything that befalls
you
remember to turn to yourself and see
what faculty you have to deal with it
if you see a handsome lad or woman you
will find
continents the faculty to employ here
if hard labor is laid upon you you will
find endurance
if reviling you will find patience to
bear evil
and if you habituate yourself in this
fashion
your external impressions will not run
away with you
here in chapter 10 towards the very end
of the chapter
epictetus is introducing a term
rather offhandedly that we ought to read
into
the entire approach of the end caribbean
he's talking about what we translate
in english as habituation the production
of a habit of a a lasting disposition
that is going to take us from moment to
moment to moment
in a kind of continuity and the greek
term here
is the the infinitive of it would be
ethids as thy
he's got it in the participle here is
ethidso menon
and he's talking about what a person
needs to do
with certain considerations he talks
about
habituating yourself in this way jutos
ethidso menon what does that mean that
means we have to try
and even sometimes succeed
over and over again until we gradually
consolidate
within the fabric of our our character
within the fabric of our personality
a new habit and it may require breaking
some old habits
you know as a ancillary to that as well
so what is he talking about here
this entire chapter has to do with
our capacities our our resources
and before going into looking at the
text itself it's worth
reflecting on this when we get ourselves
into difficult situations
one of the most common experiences that
we do have
is feeling like we're not up to
what's being demanded of us that we we
can't respond to it
that we don't have the capacity even
though other people
might have the capacity we just don't
uh you know again i've used this as an
example in other places
when when younger people these days say
the
fragment i can't even uh they're
expressing
something like that and usually it's
erroneous
when when people say i can't handle
something
at a certain level it's because they
choose not to be able to handle it there
are in fact some things
that people in their their current state
of life cannot handle
but those are much less frequent
than we would like to tell ourselves so
epictetus here
tells us about several different
problems that could come up
it says in the case of everything that
befalls you
remember to turn to yourself and see
what
faculty you have to deal with it
that's the general form and we'll come
back to that in a moment that's a great
sentence
also this is one of those dogmata that
you could you know memorize and then
repeat to yourself
if you see a handsome lad or woman you
will find
continents the faculty to employ here so
what's he talking about
well when you
look at a beautiful body where wherever
your attractions happen a lie you see
something that
as we say gets your motor running right
whatever it is that appeals to you
this could be other things too right
maybe you know you
have a craving for certain kinds of food
but when you
you see that and the whole mechanics of
your desire
starts to starts to get working
you have within yourself according to
the stoics the capacity the dunamis
for managing your desires
for what he's translating here is
continence we would translate that
today as something like self-control
you have a capacity for self-control
people who don't exhibit self-control
often tell themselves that i just don't
have self-control
and they make excuses about how the
thing itself
tempted them or the situation you know
just made it so that they had to act in
a certain way epictetus says
well no that's really a choice it may be
difficult
but it's a choice and so
when we see something that that's
attractive to us
that engages our erotic desire
we have the capacity to say um
no or we can even say well yes but only
in this respect or only
to this degree or something along those
lines and this is something
really well worth considering given the
fact that in our contemporary culture
advertisers learned long ago that um
lesson sex sells it certainly sells
something at the very least
it's it gets people's attention focused
on sex and so we're bombarded with
images constantly
that are deliberately designed to get us
to feel desire
um you know when you're watching uh
shows
on on television or on netflix or a
movie or something like that
there's often scenes that are introduced
precisely because they felt that well we
need to have something sexy at this
point right
and they don't usually pick ugly people
to be the actors they pick people that
we find
attractive people who would never in
their their if this is a real story
never look like that
if you've ever looked at those you know
true to life stories
and you look at the the person who
they're depicting they usually don't
look like a hollywood actor or
actress but this is something good to
keep in mind we do have within ourselves
maybe not fully developed the way we'd
like it that's where habituation comes
in
but we do have within ourselves the
capacity
for self-control
he says if hard labor is laid upon you
you will find an endurance
this is another thing that the greeks
stressed
there's lots of times where we have to
do work that we don't really feel like
doing
and it could be all sorts of uh examples
it could be on the job
it could be at home um you know
who who's doing the various chores that
are required to keep a household going
or you know i think even on a larger
scale you know to maintain a yard or
even bigger a farm
somebody has to do the work and
sometimes it's not
fair how it's apportioned out but if you
have endurance and when you do have the
capacity for endurance within you
you can get through it uh here should be
some other examples
you're driving somewhere your car breaks
down
do you actually get out and try to fix
it
do you take a walk and try to get to a
service station
do you try to flag a car down or do you
just sit in your car and mumble to
yourself how unfair this is
and hope that you know somebody else
will come along and solve the problem
for you i suppose you can say well we
have triple a
to to deal with that sort of thing here
in america and
i guess that's right um you know we we
outsource
a lot of our endurance in many respects
but you know you when you're called upon
do you
actually have the endurance that that's
required
that is a matter to some degree of
choice
looking within he says
if reviling when people are saying bad
things about you when people are
insulting you
when people are chewing you out as we
say
you will find patience to bear evil and
it doesn't mean that you're not saying
that it's
that it's not evil or bad um
you know he says uh an ex an exaction
right
that's what you'll find a mastery
literally
a mastery of wickedness
do you have to stoop to their level do
you have to believe what they're saying
and slink away and be depressed no
you don't have to engage them you can
actually follow epictetus
advice that he gives in other places and
come back with the one liner
well if that's what you have to say you
clearly don't know me very well because
if you did know me
then you would also know my other faults
as well
this is something that we do have as a
human capacity within us
but it does require cultivation this is
why he goes on
and he says if you habituate yourself in
this fashion your external impressions
will not run away with you your fontasia
what are the fontasia well let's go back
to the reviling
so somebody's you know somebody's in
your office
and they come in and they say terrible
things
about your work product and you know you
don't know what you're doing
and they're going to write you up and
and we can you know add all sorts of
other things in there right
you know they finish it off by saying
you should have been fired long ago
now there's a lot of external
impressions or or appearances going on
there some of them
are what the person is actually doing
and some of them
are being generated by the judgments you
yourself are bringing in which you may
have taken in
uh from the culture like well you should
never let anyone talk to you like that
because why not well if you do
then the next person who comes along is
probably also going to talk to you that
way
and then if they do that then it's going
to like be a whole crowd of people
bullying you
and you're never going to be able to get
anything done and your life is going to
be just a
miserable mass and you know notice what
we've done there we've sort of
gone out of control in the thought
process
all these appearances have been kind of
piling up
and we are the creatures that can
determine
how we use appearances whether we
believe them or not
whether we accept them as being
adequate representations of reality or
whether we
distance ourselves and say maybe i'll
test these out
and i'll use what i know as a criterion
or a canon to measure them
so epictetus says that's what we want to
do
we if we should habituate ourselves to
looking within ourselves
for resources to deal with the problems
that we encounter
and then if we do that these external
impressions
are not going to decide for us we're not
allowing them to be determinative so i
want to go back to the very first
sentence he says
remember to turn to yourself
isn't that an interesting thing to say
ultimately the goal
is not that you can simply
parrot epictetus and say well epictetus
said
rather you want to make whatever it is
that you take from stoic philosophy
from the end caridian for example part
of your own makeup
you choose whether you take in
what he has to say the dogmata
the the ideas that you can have ready to
hand
and if you do that the promise is
that you will live a happier life you
will be free
you will not be bothered by all the
other things that could go wrong
because you'll be focusing on what
really does belong to you
so this is actually some really useful
advice
and as a follow-up to that i think it's
well worth spending some time
on considering not only what could go
wrong
or what we think to be going wrong in
life
but what resources what powers what
capacities we do indeed
have within ourselves first and then
secondly what it would take for us to
further develop them
so that they would be much more
effective
never say about anything i have lost it
but only
i have given it back is your child dead
it has been given back is your wife dead
she has been given back i've had my farm
taken away
very well this too has been given back
yet it was a rascal who took it away but
what concern is it is of yours by whose
instrumentality the giver called for its
return
so long as he gives it you take care of
it as a thing that is not
your own as travelers treat their in
chapter 11 suggests a kind of
transformation of perspective that we
ought to carry out
when we feel a sense of loss
or perhaps even a sense of grief and
then might end up
because of the way in which we think and
feel end up feeling
sad or anxious or angry or any other
sorts of troubling emotions as a result
he says
never say about anything i have lost it
it's not a loss rather reframe the
situation
for yourself as i have given
it back now what's the difference there
well when you say
that i have lost it the assumption is
that the thing really does belong to you
that it is your property and you have
title to it and any sort of being
bereft of it or it being removed or it
being destroyed is somehow
against you yourself and epictetus says
no no you don't really own
any of these things that you you think
of yourself
as owning including your body
but certainly not your relationship
certainly not your
your celebrity or fame or reputation
certainly not whatever powers or
responsibilities people have
have entrusted you with or you've
acquired certainly not your wealth
certainly not your other possessions
all of that is things that in a certain
respect
don't belong to to you and may not in
fact
belong in any real sense to anyone
except for
the giver and who does he mean by the
giver uh epictetus is religious so he
does
think that this is zaus or god uh his
conception of zeus
is of sort of you know god with a
capital g
so he says is your child dead
that's you know for us an occasion to
mourn it's really a terrible thing to
lose a child
but it's not your child in the sense of
your
ownership and that because you want that
child
involved in your life the world has to
conform itself to your wishes
and make sure that that occurs
that's that's not reality you have as he
says
given it back you may not have chosen to
give it back but you have
given it back i've had my farm taken
from away is or my wife is dead
she has been given back your farm has
been given back
and now he brings up uh sort of
objection that many of us have
it's not fair in the case of a child or
a spouse it was too soon
why why did this have to happen now if i
could have just
and we go through all these mental uh
you know somersaults about what could
have been different in the situation
same thing with the farm it's a rascal
who took it away from me
you know we can say the same thing the
government took it away the bank took it
away
uh the hurricane took it away those
those looters took it away and what's
the problem with that
epictetus says well why does it matter
to you who took it away
matters is that it was given back
he says what concern is it of yours by
whose instrumentality
the the robber was just an instrument of
the giver
the giver called for its return the
hurricane the tornado
was the giver calling for its return the
disease was the giver calling for its
return the car accident
same thing so he says so long as
he gives it to you take care of it as a
thing that is not your own as travelers
treat their in
now that could be interpreted in two
very different ways
if you've ever stayed in you know public
housing like that like a dorm
room or in certain places where people
pay money and then think well since i'm
paying money i can do whatever that what
i whatever i want to to this place
you know he's not talking about that
it's not that you shouldn't take care of
the things
that you have been temporarily granted
like a child or
or a wife or a farm or a car or
a position of responsibility or
you know the capacity to engage with
other people on
on social media whatever whatever it is
that you want to talk about
you should take care of those things but
don't take care of them
as if you are taking care of something
that you
own and you're only taking care of it
because you care about
how it affects you take care of it
because that's the right thing to do
somebody's given you something you're
going to have to give it back
take care of it until you have to and
then when you have to take it back or
when they have to
when they take it back and you have to
give it back
do so willingly and you're not going to
be
so upset you'll probably still be upset
but it's not just for the stoic about
whether we are
upset or not we will get upset quite
often
it's about what happens after we get
upset do we just remain in that funk
forever
do we turn against the rest of the world
in resentment
and bitterness or do we continue on
we don't even have to say move on as if
we're leaving everything behind
do we continue on with the project and
the life that we have
chosen as the good one
if you wish to make progress dismiss
all reasoning of this sort if i neglect
my affairs i shall have nothing to live
on
if i do not punish my slave boy he will
turn out bad
for it is better to die of hunger but in
a state of freedom from grief and fear
than to live in plenty but troubled in
mind
and it is better for your slave boy to
be bad than for you to be unhappy
begin therefore with the little things
your paltry oil gets spilled
your miserable wine stolen say to
yourself
this is the price paid for a calm spirit
this is the price for peace of mind
nothing has got without a price
and when you call your slave boy bear in
mind that it is possible
he may not heed you and again that even
if he does heed
he may not do what you want done but he
is not in so happy a condition that your
peace of mind depends upon him
chapter 12 contains some really
excellent advice
for us about how to live the stoic life
and epictetus starts out saying if you
want to make progress so the assumption
there is well
perhaps you haven't been making progress
or you're
just starting out here's what you want
to
keep in mind so he says if you want to
make progress
here's what you have to do dismiss
or let go a face it's
by the way that's the same word that's
used in the new testament
in the the same uh essentially greek
writing the queen a
to talk about forgiveness letting go let
go
all reasoning of this sort if i neglect
my affairs i shall have nothing to live
on
if i if i'm not always managing my money
i'm going to be destitute if i don't
take this this
other you know job here if i don't uh
you know constantly
manage this over here everything's gonna
fall apart
if i don't punish my slave boy he will
turn out bad now we don't keep slaves
anymore
except for those of us who are
modern-day barbarians
but we we certainly have a lot of uh
relations which are quite similar where
people are
in a one-down position oftentimes
because we're paying them but not paying
them very much
we also treat our technology uh very
much as if it were we're slaves in in
the ancient
times and so he says if i don't punish
this person he's going to turn out bad
and epictetus says
look it's better to die of hunger
but in a state of freedom from grief and
fear than to live in plenty but troubled
in mind there is a
fundamental transformation
of of value that goes on within
stoic philosophy if you really buy stoic
philosophy then what
counts as good is what's within you
are you troubled or are you untroubled
are you
miserable or are you happy and so
you know living in a place where you
have enough to eat but you're
miserable all the time is not actually a
game
according to to epictetus so he says
it's better for your slave boy to be bad
then for you to be unhappy
if you expect perfection
out of everybody around you you are
going to be the most
miserable person around if you even
confine yourself
just to the things that you think you're
buying
or you have a right to to you know be be
insistent about you're probably going to
be unhappy
if you go into a restaurant here's
here's a sort of classic example
if you go into a restaurant and you
order some food there's many ways in
which things can go bad
who does it almost always get taken out
on at least in american restaurants
on the server because the server is the
interface
between the person who's eating the the
patron
and the entire rest of the restaurant
the front of the house and the back of
the house
sometimes the manager might get called
in as well but you know the server comes
out
and if you expect that that somebody who
is serving person after person after
person
is somehow supposed to treat you as if
you're kings and queens
even if you are paying you know lots and
lots of money you're setting yourself up
for some disappointment and
there's all sorts of ways in which
things can go wrong you know the cook
might not be totally on top of their
game
maybe the dishes weren't washed as well
as you would like and you
notice a speck of food it's up to you
whether you allow that sort of thing to
to really upset you or not so he goes on
and he says begin with little things
why little things because it's too hard
to do the big things right off the bat
we have to get some some you know a few
wins
under our belt so we feel like we have
some momentum begin with the little
things your paltry oil
gets spilled your miserable wine stolen
say to yourself
instead of saying who knocked over this
oil
what the hell is going on here who who
stole my wine
right instead of saying those things he
says say something else
say to yourself well this is the price
paid for a calm spirit this the price
for peace of mind
if i want to keep my cool if i want to
stay on track with my project of
working on my life and someday down the
line
actually not getting upset about these
things like i'm getting upset right now
then what i need to say is well that's
the price that i have to pay
this is not just a matter of passivity
of just sucking up whatever anybody
doles out to you
this is being realistic about how these
things affect you
and whether you indeed play some role in
that
or have a choice in whether these things
affect you and that's a very important
thing to keep in mind because if you
don't
constantly remember that early on as a
stoic
you won't make progress so he says
nothing has gotten without a price
everything costs something
we tend to think that when once we
purchase something
it's ours we get to do whatever we want
with it
if i've paid the price everything better
be perfect
now how often is that actually the case
think about the wide panorama
of human activities and products
that you might pay some money for
or you might get in some other way you
know you know somebody who knows
somebody
and you chat chat around with them and
they you make them feel good so they'll
give you something free right they'll
comp it to you but you're paying for it
everything has a price if you're not
willing to pay the price
don't expect the thing and
part of the price is being to being
willing
to write some things off and to let them
go
to say this doesn't matter quite so much
so um he says uh
when you call your slave boy bear in
mind it's possible he may not heed you
and again
even if he does heed he may not do what
you want done
but he is not in so happy a condition
that your peace of mind depends upon him
unless you choose for that to be the
case and from the stoic perspective if
you choose
to make how you feel dependent
on somebody else who you think is in a
lower position than you
you're in a certain respect crazy and
you probably should take a close look
at what's going on and fix that so you
know he says
when you're when you're asking for
somebody to do something
they may not do it they may not pay
attention to you at all
you may have to shout several times to
get their attention
even after you tell them they may not do
what you want them to do
i see this with students all the time
sometimes students surpass my
expectations as an instructor
and that's a pleasant surprise and a lot
of times
students need quite a few reminders hey
you know there's an assignment due
or you know you're already late with the
assignment uh
so maybe you want to turn it in you'll
still get some credit or
they turn something in you're like you
didn't read the instruction sheet at all
did you
and that's a problem you you actually
need to
follow the directions for this and do
the assignment
according to the criteria that i gave
you so that you learn
what i want you to learn in the process
you know whether or not i
feel okay shouldn't depend on whether
those those students do what they're
going to do
i mean not if i'm a realist about life
and about human nature
and about the many different ways in
which things can go astray
and we can apply this to anything you
like you can apply this to the workplace
you can apply this to your relationships
whether romantic
familial friendship you can apply this
to going to a concert
you can apply this to eating in a
restaurant this can be
applied to practically anything in life
where
what the outcome is is dependent to some
degree
on somebody else it's silly as he says
in that last sentence
for us to give so much power to other
people
that we allow them to determine whether
we're going to be happy or upset
you